linear regression versus
logistic regression my name is richard
kirschner with the simply learn team
that's www.simplylearn.com
get certified get ahead in this video
we're going to cover the difference
between the linear
and logistic regression models so what
is in it for you
we're going to start with an
introduction to regression then we'll go
into an introduction to
classification what is linear regression
what is logistics regression and then
logistics versus linear regression
and we'll do a quick demo so you can see
what the differences are and how they
function
so we start looking at regression
regression is literally talking about
numbers
that's where that term comes from and so
regression is a statistical method which
allows us to predict a dependent output
variable based on
values of independent input variables
and you can see here we have our
independent input variables in this case
our team in the back put together an
image of a bunch of vegetables
it goes through the regression model or
the recipe or the little
programming setup and then we have a
dependent output variable
and so the output is based on what our
input is and what we're looking for so
when we talk about
we're going to start with our
introduction to classification and so we
want to start with
our classification model
and we talk about the classification
classification
allows us to divide a given input into
some predefined categories
the output is discrete value it's
distinct like 0 1
true false or predefined output label
class and so you can see here we have
our independent input variables which is
our
bag of vegetables it goes through our
classification model
and it comes out and it says vegetables
and different groceries and so you have
a categorical output
variable a lot of times when we're
talking about programming
the broccoli would be one output and
it's either broccoli true or false the
carrot be one output and so forth
so if so if that is um uh
categorical what is a linear regression
how does that have to fit all together
so linear regression is a machine
learning model that is used to predict
the values
of output variables based on the value
of the input variables
consider the data given and you can see
here we have a group of data going up
and if you kind of mentally group it
together you can see there's a pattern
almost like a line
the input variable x are called
independent
variable and are used to predict the
values of the response variable
the output variable y is called the
dependent
variable its value depends on the value
of
x linear regression aims to find the
relationship between
input and output variables by plotting a
line which
best fits the data given to it now not
all linear regression models use a line
through the data they use a lot of
different ways to solve it
but we talk about linear they usually
mean a line
versus other different models regression
means that we're going to be putting out
a number
and you can see here we have our
dependent variable y
and based on x you can kind of guess
what y is going to be
and this can be in three dimensions four
dimensions five dimensions so you might
have
multiple inputs you might have a bunch
of features coming in and you're going
to try to guess which one is going to
have the right output for y and what
that value is
the equation which can be used to fit a
line is the equation of a straight line
the equation gives the output variable
based on the input variable
and inclination of the line and you can
see here we have
y equals b naught which is the
y-intercept y is our output
plus b1 of x plus e
and the b1 of x that is our
slope if you remember from euclidean
geometry usually you see
y equals mx plus b and then you have an
error term
and the error term is pretty important
because that's how we're going to
calculate it we want to find the error
and minimize the error
now this is a linear regression model
we're looking for a line we only have
one input you can do this with multiple
inputs
you can actually have a b1 x1 plus b2 x2
and so forth
there's a lot of different formulas they
use to fit the model
the concept is important that you're
basically finding
a mathematical formula that fits the
data as best as you can
and have minimal error the data given
represents the amount
a company puts into advertisement and
the resulting cells in thousands
using regression given the advertisement
amount we can predict
the how many cells it will take place
and you can see here this is a very
common one very simple one
most people when you're looking at this
kind of linear regression do it
by looking at it and saying oh yeah i
can figure that one out if i put 50
bucks in
i'll get 100 cells if i put 150 in i get
275 cells
if i put 200 in i get 300 cells if i put
250
and i get 400 cells what is 175 going to
be
and you can probably guess you can
probably look at this and
guess i'll be around 280 something
somewhere in there
with the help of linear regression we
can plot the graph of cells versus
advertisement and find the line
of best fit between them and using that
find the values of the missing variable
and again you can see right here we know
it's between 150 and 200
we know our data kind of has a nice
linear
increase and you can like i said usually
with something this simple you eyeball
it but we usually we're talking about a
business model
they get very complicated you can have
up to 26 30 features in them
and so this simple model gives you an
idea what's going on but when you try to
eyeball something
that complicated you really need machine
learning
program to put it together and you can
see here where we're guessing the number
of cells
so what is logistic regression logistic
regression
is a classification algorithm which is
used to predict the category
of dependent variable based on values of
independent variable
its output is 0 1. so if you remember if
we go back
you see here we're putting an output
we're going to look for like i said
roughly 175 i guess around 180
but 175 is what their guess was you can
actually do the math and have a more
concrete number
but if you look at the variance of the
data that's a good guess it's going to
be somewhere in there
and so you can guess how much you can
predict how much marketing you need to
put in
to get those kind of cells when we look
at a regression model for category
a logistic think category when you think
logistic
you really want to zero one i want a yes
or no true false
is this what it is or it's not what it
is consider the graph
shown the input values are of two types
and are taken at 0
and 1. a threshold is set which will be
used to classify values into the two
categories
values of y above this threshold will be
classified as category 1 and values
below the threshold will be taken as
category 0.
values of y above this threshold will be
classified as category 1 and values
below the threshold will be taken as
category 0.
the given equation is used to represent
a sigmoid function y is the probability
of an output
c is a constant y are the various
dependent variables and b0
b1 gives us the intercept values
and you can see here i was talking about
earlier where you can have just a single
input or you might have multiple inputs
on here this is with the sigmoid it uses
the log function of y
over one plus y and when you do that
it's going to give you a very clear
answer it's either going to be 0 or 1
there's a little discrepancy right in
the middle but for the most part it's
very clear which way it's going to go
and you can see here we have our
intercept or b naught just like we did
with our
linear equation and we have our input
b1 x1 which is kind of like your slope
and then you have your constant c the
formulas are very similar it's just
how do we activate it do we give you the
raw number which tells you what
percentage we think it's going to be
or do we convert it to a 0 1 value
consider
credit card numbers in their transaction
history
we want to classify the credit cards as
fraudulent and legitimate we can do this
with logistic regression
this is a very common use of machine
learning
it's actually a fairly simple problem to
solve
when you're looking at this kind of
thing because you have a huge history of
what people are making as purchases
the bank can run it through one of these
models and say
you know is it is it fraud or is it not
should i you know put a hold on this and
contact
the customer or should i let it go
through because they're making their
usual purchases
uh so consider the credit card numbers
we want to classify the credit cards as
fraudulent
and so you can see here we have like a
group that we put together
and like i said they know they're
fraudulent these are fraudulent charges
that they have incurred
the customer calls in and says hey
cancel that charge and
you go through that nice fun thing of
whether you have to pay for it or not
and how to block it and how to get that
money back
and you have all your good purchases
you've done one of the cool things
about these two models
and we talked you know we're very brief
talking about how they function and
you're just doing a
sigmoid activation there's different
activations depending on what you're
doing and how they
function is that these are very simple
to see you can see how they work
and then you start taking these pieces
and you can now build
larger models and you might have part of
the model that predicts
fraudulent not fraudulent and you might
have the other part of the module that
says out of these fraudulent charges
what percentage of these what's the cost
going to be to the bank
to cover them or not cover them or
i mean there's a lot of different things
that can mix in there and so these are
really a cool basis of where you start
and this is where
right now pretty much all machine
learning starts is based on
these two concepts even the most
complicated ones start with this idea
and so there's a logic here that you
should be noting versus just
exactly instead of looking at just a
linear regression model there's all
kinds of regression models that come out
of this
so we put them side to back side we have
our linear regression
which is a predictive number used to
predict a dependent output variable
based on
independent input variable accuracy is a
measured
using least squares estimation
so that's where you take you could also
use absolute value
the least squares is more popular
there's reasons for that mathematically
and also for computer run time
uh but it does give you an accuracy
based on the
the least square estimation the best fit
line is a straight line
and clearly that's not always used at
all the regression models there's a lot
of variations on that
the output is a predicted integer value
again this is what we're talking about
when we talk about linear regression and
we're talking about regression it means
the numbers coming out
linear usually means we're looking for
that line versus a different model
and it's used in business domain
forecasting stocks uh
it's used as a basis of all of most
predictions with numbers so if you're
looking at a lot of numbers you're
probably looking at
a linear regression model
for instance if you do just the high
lows of the stock exchange
and you're going to take a lot more of
that if you want to make money off the
stock
you'll find that the linear regression
model fits uh probably better than
almost any of the other models with even
you know high-end neural networks and
all these other different machine
learning and ai models
because they're numbers they're just a
straight set of numbers you have a high
value a low value volume
that kind of thing so when you're
looking at something that's straight
numbers and are connected in that way
usually you're talking about a linear
regression model
that's where you want to start a
logistic regression model
used to classify dependent output
variable based on
independent input variable so just like
the linear regression model and like all
of our machine learning tools
you have your features coming in and so
in this case you might have
a label you know an image or something
like that is probably the very popular
thing right now labeling
broccoli and vegetables or whatever
accuracy is measured using
maximum likelihood estimation the best
fit is given by a curve
and we saw that we're talking about
linear regression you definitely are
talking about straight line
although there is other regression
models that don't use straight lines
and usually when you're looking at a
logistic regression
the math as you saw was still kind of a
euclidean line
but it's now got that sigmoid activation
which turns it into a heavily weighted
curve
and the output is a binary value between
0 and 1.
and it's used for classification image
processing as i mentioned is
is what people usually think of although
they use it for classification of
like a window of things so you could
take a window of stock history
and you could cla generate
classifications based on that and
separate the data that way
if it's going to be that this particular
pattern occurs is going to be upward
trending or downward trending
in fact a number of stock
traders use that not to tell them how
much to bid or what to bid
but they use it as to whether it's worth
looking at the stock or not whether the
stock's going to go down or go up
and it's just a zero one do i care do i
even want to look at it
so let's do a demo so you can get a
picture of what this looks like in
python code
let's predict the price at which
insurance should be sold to a particular
customer
based on their medical history we will
also classify on a mushroom data set to
find the poisonous
and non-poisonous mushrooms
and when you look at these two datas the
first one
we're looking at the price so the price
is a number
so let's predict the price which the
insurance should be sold to and the
second one
is we're looking at either as poisonous
or it's not poisonous
so first off before we begin the demo
i'm in the anaconda navigator
in this one i've loaded the python 3.6
and using the jupiter notebook and you
can use jupyter notebook by itself
you can use the jupiter lab which allows
multiple tabs it's basically the
notebook
with tabs on it but the jupyter notebook
is just fine and it'll go into
google chrome which is what i'm using
for my internet explorer
and from here we open up new and you'll
see python 3
and again this is loaded with python 3.6
and we're doing the linear versus logic
uh regression or logit
you'll see logit
as one of the one of the names that kind
of pops up when you do a search on here
uh but it is a logic we're looking at
the logistic regression models
and we'll start with the linear
regression uh because it's easy to
understand you draw a line through stuff
and so in programming we got a lot of
stuff to
unfold here in our in our startup as we
preload all of our different parts
and let's go ahead and break this up we
have at the beginning
import pandas so this is our data frame
uh it's just a way of storing the data
think of
a we talk about data frame think of a
spreadsheet
rows and columns it's a nice way of
viewing the data
and then we have we're going to be
bringing in our pre-processing labeling
coder i'll show you what that is when we
get down to it it's easier to see in the
data
but there's some data in here like sex
it's male or female
so it's not like an actual number it's
either one or the other
that kind of stuff ends up being encoded
that's what this label encoder is right
here
we have our test split model if you're
going to build a model
you do not want to use all the data you
want to use some of the data
and then test it to see how good it is
and if it can't have seen the data
you're testing on
until you're ready to test it on there
and see how good it is
and then we have our logistic regression
model
our categorical one and then we have our
linear regression model
these are the two these right here let
me just um clear all that there we go
these two right here are what this is
all about logistic
versus linear is it categorical are we
looking for a true false
or are we looking for a specific number
and then finally um usually at the very
end
we have to take and just ask how
accurate is our model did it work
if you're trying to predict something in
this case we're going to be doing
um insurance costs
how close to the insurance cost is a
measure that we expect it to be you know
if you're an insurance company
you don't want to promise to pay
everybody's medical bill and not be able
to
in the case of the mushrooms you
probably want to know just how much at
risk you are for following
this model uh as so far as whether
you're gonna
get a eat a poisonous mushroom and die
or not
so we'll look at both of those and we'll
get talk a little bit more about the
shortcomings and the uh
value of these different processes so
let's go ahead and run this
this is loaded the data set on here and
then
because we're in jupyter notebook i
don't have to put the print on there
we just do data set and by and it prints
out all the different data on here and
you can see here for our insurance
because we're starting with
we're loading that with our pandas and
it prints it in a nice format where you
can see the age sex
uh body mass index number children
smoker
so this might be something that the
insurance company gets from the doctor
says hey we're gonna
this is what we need to know to give you
a quote for what we're gonna charge you
for your
insurance and you can see that it has
1338 rows and seven columns you can
count the columns one two three four
five six
seven so there's seven columns on here
and the column we're really interested
in is charges
i want to know what the charges are
going to be what can i expect
not a very good arrow drawn
what to expect them to charge on there
uh so is this going to be
you know is this person going to cost me
uh sixteen thousand eight hundred eighty
four dollars
or is this person only going to cost me
uh
3866 how do we guess that so that we can
guess
what the minimal charge is for their
insurance
and then there's one other thing you
really need to notice on this data
and i mentioned it before but i'm going
to mention it again because
pre-processing data is so much of the
work in data science
sex well how do you how do you deal with
female versus male
are you a smoker yes or no what does
that mean
region how do you look at region it's
not a number how do you draw a line
between southwest and northwest
um you know they're objects it's either
your southwest or your northwest
it's not like i'm southwest i guess you
could do longitudinal latitude but the
data doesn't come in like that
it comes in as true false or whatever
you know it's either your southwest or
your northwest
so we need to do a little bit of
pre-processing of the data on here
to make this work
oops there we go okay so let's take a
look and see what we're doing with
pre-processing
and again this is really where you spend
a lot of time with data sciences trying
to understand how and why
you need to do that and so we're going
to do you'll see right up here
label and then we're going to do the do
a label encoder one of the modules we
brought in so this is
sk learns label encoder
i like the fact that it's all pretty
much automated but if you're doing a lot
of work with label encoder you should
start to understand how that fits
and then we have label dot fit
right here where we're going to go ahead
and do the data set
dot sex dot drop duplicates and then for
data set sex we're going to do the label
transform the data sought
sex and so we're looking right here at
male or female and so it usually just
converts it to a zero one because
there's only two choices on here
same thing with the smoker it's zero or
one so we're gonna
transfer the transa change the smoker
0 1 on this and then finally we did
region
down here region does it a little bit
different we'll take a look at that
and it it's i think in this case it's
probably going to do it because we did
it on this label transform
with this particular setup it gives each
region
a number like 0 1 2 3. so let's go and
take a look and see what that looks like
i'm going to run this and you can see
that our new data set
has age that's still a number uh sex is
zero or one
so zero is female one is male number of
children we left that alone
uh smoker one or zero says no or yes on
there we actually just do
one for no zero or no yeah one for no
i'm not sure how it organized them but
it turns the smoker into zero or one yes
or no
and then regen it did this as zero one
two three so it's three regions now
a lot of times in in when you're working
with data science and you're dealing
with uh
regions or even word analysis um
instead of doing one column and labeling
it zero one two three
a lot of times you increase your
features and so you would have region
northwest would be one column yes or no
region southwest would be one column yes
or no
true zero one uh but for this this
this particular setup this will work
just fine on here
now we spent all that time getting it
set up uh here's the fun part
uh here's the part where we're actually
using our setup on this and you'll see
right here we have our
y linear regression data set drop the
charges
because that's what we want to predict
and
so our x i'm sorry our x linear data set
drop the charges because that's what
we're going to predict we're predicting
charges right here so we don't want that
as our input for our features
and our y output is charges that's what
we want to guess
we want to guess what the charges are
and then what we talked about earlier is
we don't want to do all the data at once
so we're going to take 0.3
it means 30 percent we're going to take
30 percent of our data
and it's going to be as the train as the
testing site so here's our y
test and our x test down there
and so that part our model will never
see it
until we're ready to test to see how
good it is
and then of course right here you'll see
our training set
and this is what we're going to train it
we're going to trade it on 70 of the
data
and then finally the big ones this is
where all the magic happens
this is where we're going to create our
magic setup and that is right here our
linear model
we're going to set it equal to the
linear regression model and then we're
going to fit
the data on here
and then at this point i always like to
pull up
if you if you're working with a new
model it's good to see where it comes
from
this comes from the scikit learn
and this is the sk learn linear model
linear regression that we imported
earlier
and you can see they have different
parameters the basic parameter works
great if you're dealing with just
numbers
i mentioned that earlier with stock high
lows
this model will do as good as any other
model out there for do if you're doing
just the very basic high lows and
looking for a linear fit
a regression model fit and once you
one of the things when i am looking at
this is i look for methods
and you'll see here's our fit that we're
using right now and here's our predict
and we'll actually do a little bit in
the middle here as far as looking at
some of the
parameters hidden behind it the math
that we talked about earlier
and so we go in this we go ahead and run
this
you'll see it loads the linear
regression model and just has a nice
output that says hey
i loaded the linear regression model and
then the second part is we did the fit
and so this model is now trained our
linear model is now trained on the
training data
and so one of the things we can look at
is the um
for idx and column name and enumerate x
linear trained columns
become an interesting thing this prints
out the coefficients
uh so when you're looking at the back
end of the data
you remember we had that formula uh bx
x1
plus bx x2 plus the inner plus the
intercept
uh and so forth these are the actual
coefficients that are in here this is
what it's actually multiplying these
numbers by
and you can see like region gets a minus
value so when it heads it up
i guess region you can read a lot into
these numbers
it gets very complicated there's ways to
mess with them
if you're doing a basic linear
regression model usually don't look at
them too closely
but you might start looking in these and
saying hey you know what smoker look how
smoker
impacts the cost it's just massive
so this is a flag that hey the value of
the smoker
really affects this model
and then you can see here where the body
mass index
so somebody who is overweight is
probably less healthy and more likely to
have
cost money and then of course age is a
factor
and then you can see down here we have a
sexist and a factor also and it just
it changes as you go in there negative
number it probably has its own meaning
on there
again it gets really complicated when
you dig into the
workings and how the linear model works
on that
and so we can also look at the intercept
this is just kind of fun
so it starts at this negative number and
then adds all these numbers to it that's
all that means that's our intercept on
there
and that fits the data we have on that
and so you can see right here
we can go back and
let's give you just a second there we go
we can go ahead and predict the unknown
data and we can print that out
and if you're going to create a model to
predict something
we'll go ahead and predict it here's our
y prediction value
linear model predict and then we'll go
ahead and create a new data frame
in this case from our x linear test
group
we'll go ahead and put the cost back
into this data frame
and then the predicted cost we're going
to make that equal to our y prediction
and so when we pull this up uh you can
see here that we have
the actual cost and what we predicted
the cost is going to be
there's a lot of ways to measure the
accuracy on there but we're going to go
ahead and jump
into our mushroom data
and so in this you can see here we've
run our basic model we built our
coefficients you can see the intercept
the back end
you can see how we're generating a
number here
now with mushrooms we want a yes or no
we want to know whether we can eat them
or not
and so here's our mushroom file we're
going to run this take a look at the
data
and again you can ask for a copy of this
file send a note over to simplylearn.com
and you can see here that we have a
class
the cap shape cap surface and so forth
so there's a lot of feature
in fact there's 23 different columns in
here going across
and when you look at this i'm not even
sure what these
particular like p e e p e i don't even
know what the class
is on this i'm going to guess by the
notes that the class
is poisonous or edible
so if you remember before we had to do a
little pre-coding on our data
same thing with here we have our cap
shape
which is b or x or k
we have cap color these really aren't
numbers so it's really hard to do
anything with just a single number so we
need to go ahead and turn those into a
label encoder which again
there's a lot of different encoders with
this particular label encoder is just
switching it
to 0 1 2 3 and giving it an integer
value
in fact if you look at all the columns
all of our columns are
labels and so we're just going to go
ahead and loop through all the columns
in the data
and we're going to transform it into a
label encoder and so when we run this
you can see how this gets shifted from
x bx x k to 0 1 2 3 4
5 or whatever it is class is 0 1
1 being poisonous 0 looks like it's
editable
and so forth on here so we're just
encoding it
if you were doing this project depending
on the results you might encode it
differently
like i mentioned earlier you might
actually increase the number of features
as opposed to laboring at 0 1 2 3 4 5.
in this particular example it's not
going to make that big of a difference
how we encode it
and then of course we're looking for the
class
whether it's poisonous or edible so
we're going to drop the class in our x
logistics model and we're going to
create our y logistics model is based on
that class so here's our x
y and just like we did before
we're going to go ahead and split it
using 30 for test
70 to program the model on here
and that's right here whoops there we go
there's our train and test
and then you'll see here on this next
setup
this is where we create our model all
the magic happens right here
we go ahead and create a logistics model
i have up the max iterations
if you don't change this for this
particular problem
you'll get a warning that says this has
not converged
because then that that's what it does is
it goes through the math and it goes
hey can we minimize the error and it
keeps finding a lower and lower
error and it still is changing that
number so that means it hasn't conversed
yet it hasn't find the lowest amount of
error it can
and the default is 100. there's a lot of
settings in here
so when we go in here to let me pull
that up from the sk learn
so we pull that up from the sk learn
model
you can see here we have our logistic it
has our different settings on here
that you can mess with most of these
work pretty solid on this particular
setup so you don't usually mess a lot
usually i find myself adjusting the
iteration and i'll get that warning and
then increase the iteration on there
and just like the other model you can go
just like you did with the other model
we can scroll down here and look for our
methods
and you can see there's a lot of methods
available on here
and certainly there's a lot of different
things you can do with it
but the most basic thing we do is we fit
our model
make sure it's set right and then we
actually predict something with it
so those are the two main things we're
going to be looking at on this model
is fitting and predicting there's a lot
of cool things you can do that are more
advanced
but for the most part these are the two
which i use when i'm going into one of
these models and setting them up
so let's go ahead and close out of our
sklearn setup on there
and we'll go ahead and run this and you
can see here it's now loaded this up
there we now have
a logistic model
and we've gone ahead and done a predict
here also just like i was showing you
earlier
uh so here's where we're actually
predicting the data so we've done our
first two lines of code as we create the
model
we fit the model to our training data
and then we go ahead and predict for our
test data
now in the previous model we didn't dive
into
the test score i think i just showed you
a graph
and we can go in there and there's a lot
of tools to do this we're going to look
at
the model score on this one let me just
go ahead and run the model score
and it says that it's pretty accurate
we're getting a roughly 95
accuracy well that's good 195 percent
accuracy
95 accuracy might be good for a lot of
things
but when you look at something as far as
whether you're going to pick a mushroom
on the side of the trail and eat it
we might want to look at the confusion
matrix and for that we're going to put
in
our y logistic test the actual values of
edible and unedible
and we're going to put in our prediction
value
and if you remember on here i believe
it's poisonous was 1
0 is edible so let's go ahead and run
that
0 1 0 is good so here is
a confusion matrix and this is if you're
not familiar with these
we have true true true false
true false false false so it says
out of the edible mushrooms we correctly
labeled 1201
mushrooms edible that were edible and we
correctly measured
1113 poisonous mushrooms
as poisonous but here's the kicker
i labeled 56 edible mushrooms
as being poisonous well that's not too
big of a deal we just don't eat them
but i measured 68 mushrooms as being
edible that were poisonous
so probably not the best choice to use
this model to predict whether you're
going to eat a mushroom or not
and you'd want to dig a little deeper
before you
start picking mushrooms off the side of
the trail so a little warning there when
you're looking at any of these data
models
looking at the error and how that error
fits in with what domain you're in
domain in this case being edible
mushrooms
be a little careful make sure that
you're looking at them correctly
so we've looked at uh edible or not
edible we've looked at
a regression model as far as
the in values what's going to be the
cost and what our predicted cost is so
we can start
figuring out how much to charge these
people for their insurance
and so these really are the fundamentals
of data science
when you pull them together when i say
data science to talk about your machine
learning code
and hopefully you got a little bit out
of here again you can contact our simply
learn team
and get a copy of these files or get
more information on this
so that wraps up our demo for today
thank you for joining us at simplylearn
for more information
please visit simplylearn.com
www.simplylearn.com
get certified get ahead
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here